week on book notes our guest is
journalist bill thomas
he joins us to discuss his recent book
club fed
power money sex and violence on capitol
hill
bill thomas where did you get the title
club fed
club med club fed i uh it occurred to me
that uh a lot of a lot of the time on
capitol hill is spent uh not doing the
work of the public but really really
playing or playing it being a public
servant and the uh and the title sort of
grew naturally out of that out of that
thought
what does it mean
um
i suppose maybe some of your viewers
know this but most people don't realize
that the typical congressional work week
lasts from
sometime tuesday morning until maybe
sometime thursday afternoon and
the weekend the congressional weekend is
a little longer in most cases than the
congressional work week
uh and club fed
is meant to suggest that
all of the activity that goes on on
capitol hill is not just not really
wouldn't follow under fall under the
heading of public service but
self-service
and in in in many cases recreation
let me uh from time to time take the
other side just so for sure purpose of
uh discussion
if a member were sitting here they'd say
well mr thomas you don't know what
you're talking about i leave here on
thursday i fly back to my district i
spend friday saturday sunday monday
morning in constituent service going to
dinners
speaking to service clubs
handshaking office hours town meetings
i'm exhausted
i'm sure they are
i what i tried to do here was write an
entertaining book about a subject that
that most people take i think too
seriously um politics i began with the
assumption that politics is show
business
and for the most part politicians are
are actors or performance artists some
some in the best sense some are really
nothing more than lounge acts
but a lot of what is called work on
capitol hill is really performance
and i'm sure they get they get tired
after a weekend back in their districts
or
wherever they are
raising money or trying to influence
people but it's not it's not work in the
in the way that most people think of
work it's performing it's acting it's
raising money it's
putting on a show
where are you from i'm from chicago grew
up here in washington however and uh
have lived here off and on for most of
my life where did you go to school i
went to school at university of
washington in seattle what'd you study
uh comparative literature
taught uh taught there for a while at
goucher college in baltimore until
around 1975
and have been writing ever since worked
for the baltimore sun i was reported for
the sun
for about five years worked a
congressional quarterly
worked at roll call and still
occasionally do some things for roll
call and most recently have worked for
the la times sunday magazine
what is roll call
roll call
is a
how can i put this roll call is a
newspaper it's a little like the wall
street journal uh it covers goings on
and capitol hill comes out a couple of
times a week it combines a little bit of
uh
nuts and bolts hill reporting with uh
reporting on hill sociology it's a
little bit like the hollywood reporter
in some sense it keeps track of the
industry
and it reports on personalities in the
news on capitol hill and has fun with
politics how long do you work there uh i
started there when jim glassman and i
came to roll call after arthur levitt
bought it in uh 19
was that 86 i think 86 or 87
and stayed with roll call until about
1990.
uh when i uh got a contract to write an
earlier book
you say in the book that
and you thank sid udain you used to own
roll call great guy
you basically you say also that in
interviewing city dana he wants to go
back to the old days
i think he does sid uh uh created roll
call
in in 1959 sid had actually been working
in in hollywood doing some work for the
hollywood reporter in the hollywood
citizen news i don't know if that exists
any longer but it was sort of a
hollywood community newspaper
and sid uh
sid like politics but but he uh but he
realized very quickly that there wasn't
any any sort of community newspaper for
capitol hill in the early 50s or mid 50s
and he came here and started roll call
sid actually discovered a lot of a lot
of big talents along the way and putting
together uh the early the early roll
call one of whom was mark russell whom
he discovered working in a in a in a bar
a strip bar uh in in washington the club
maryland and uh sid nurtured nurtured
mark russell mark russell did some
writing for the early roll call and
they're still great friends
but the point i want to make was that
you said that he has sold it
he sold roll call in um in 1986 1985 86
to arthur levitt who's now the sec
chairman she said for five hundred
thousand dollars somewhere and then
arthur levitt sold it to the economist
for 15 million somewhere in the
neighborhood of 15 million from 1986 to
what 1993 or so
that made some money how could i mean
how could you go from a publication on
capitol hill
being worth a half a million dollars to
being worth 15 million dollars
well advertising picked up let's let's
put it that way uh where's the
advertising come from
a lot of the advertising and roll call a
lot of advertising and newspapers that
cover capitol hill is advertising meant
to influence congress corporate uh
corporations speaking to legislators and
speaking to lawmakers a lot of sort of
corporate i guess you might call them
corporate vanity ads
ads intended to influence opinion makers
lawmakers in one way or another and you
find you find a lot of this sort of
thing in national journal congressional
court early roll call
there's a new publication on capitol
hill called the hill now you see a lot
of it in there are you a party member
republican or democrat no i'm
independent
what do you think of politicians in
general just personally personally i uh
i find them fascinating to tell you the
truth i find i find people who go into
politics uh very interesting people it's
a mystery to me what makes them tick and
i love to talk to them about their
ambitions and where they're coming from
uh i had an opportunity a couple of
years ago to cover the congressional
orientation for the la times magazine
and spent about a week and a half with
new members of congress
uh it was interesting to watch them
become
in effect
congressmen and congresswomen over the
period of this two or three week
training session
uh they they came to capitol hill one
day were kind of raw rookies you can see
they were intimidated many of them were
a little awed by the whole thing but
after their
after
really being
introduced to the club as it were
you could watch you watch them become
become members of congress um
what motivates people to go into
politics uh
i couldn't i couldn't begin to tell you
but i i like to watch
politicians perform i like i like to
watch them in the act of being
politicians i remember uh a friend of
mine told me a story once about having a
conversation with charlie rose
the congressman congressman charlotte
not
we should make that distinction not the
talk show host the congressman from
north carolina very powerful guy on
capitol hill he's head of the house
administration committee in fact runs
the congressional orientation program
but this uh friend was having a
conversation with rose and behind rose
was c-span playing
and it was a tape of the previous day's
activity on capitol hill and every time
rose came on the television set this was
the set behind rose now he would stop
his conversation and turn around watch
himself
when he was finished speaking get back
to his conversation
it's it's that sort of thing it's that
uh i guess you might call it a
psychological impulse to to to be a
politician that i find really
interesting about politics and about
people who go into it when was the last
word written by you that's a good
question this book
uh sometime in maybe the middle of june
end of june somewhere in there because a
lot happened since you wrote well it's
happened
i tried to squeeze in as much as i
possibly maybe maybe uh july i'm not
quite sure but i tried to get as much as
i could in about
white water and health care uh let me at
the last minute what i'm getting is let
me pick chapter 13 tony cuello
before tony cuello came back
to this town
you wrote a lot about him you
interviewed yeah tony cuella is a very
interesting guy um
when tony cuala left
uh left congress under a cloud in 1989
i'm some of your viewers may recall that
uh tony koala was involved in a a junk
bond deal with the beverly hills
investment broker and was right around
the time that jim wright had gotten into
trouble uh tony cuella i for whatever
reason decided it would be better just
to leave rather than have to go through
an ethics committee hearing he had
befriended john mack a lobbyist who had
uh
he'd been an investment partner with
mack in a couple of real estate deals in
california mack had
worked for wright and mack it was
revealed in washington post story had
beaten up a woman after uh in virginia
17 years earlier and got a very light
prison sentence after the after after
his trial and wright had helped with
lessening the sentence apparently uh in
mack's case and coella was defending mac
in 1989 was a very bad year for
democrats and things were getting very
messy and cuellar had cuello had left
congress and
he went to work for wertheim schroeder a
new york investment firm and i thought
he'd make a very interesting profile
store and i did an interview with him in
an article about him in manhattan inc
clay felker's magazine which no longer
exists
and in the five years since i'd done
that story quello had become very
important figure in new york investment
banking and i thought it might be
interesting to look at tony cuella as
the perfect example in a way of
what happens to somebody who's that
powerful on capitol hill in a life after
congress and uh i went and interviewed
him last
october i think it was
at in new york in his office in new york
we started talking about politics and
investing and you could see in the five
years or so he'd been working in new
york that he'd
you could see him chomping at the bit to
get back into politics he told me at the
time he'd been talking to people like
newt gingrich and bill clinton and he'd
really never lost touch with washington
he lives in alexandria which is not too
far from
capitol hill and he spent his weekends
here and tried to get back to washington
as often as he could
and we talked about money we talked
about uh
his background his his jesuit school uh
seminary training
his relationship with bob hope which he
credits with saving him from
uh his a few early mistakes that he made
in his life and actually he credits bob
hope with uh suggesting they get into
politics and he said when he had some
problems in politics in 1989 he called
bob hope asked him what he should do and
he said hope suggested that he get into
investment banking he's a source of good
advice but we got into money can i read
a quote yeah please i i i think this is
your quote i understand what is
government tonight
it's a money game but everybody in
congress is embarrassed to talk about it
they're embarrassed by the money they
give out embarrassed by the money they
raised embarrassed to vote for their own
salaries to me it was a big facade
everybody knew what they were doing they
just pretended they were doing something
else that the game they were playing was
about public policy when in reality it's
all about money
well it's hard to disagree with that
considering that members of congress
have to raise about seventeen thousand
dollars a week in order to pay for
re-election campaigns it is about money
are you
are you agreeing with him that
everything over there is about money
it's about access to money it's about uh
i'd say if you want to stay in on the
job it's about raising enough money to
be re-elected i think the the the the
job of a congressman has two jobs or a
senator has two jobs performing a public
service and if he's interested in
staying on the job getting reelected and
that effort starts on day one
uh you
again going back to the freshman
orientation program that i uh that i uh
witnessed a couple of years ago
you can see that uh
interest in earning in raising money and
trying to find out ways to raise money
uh earn money for your re-election
campaign start on day one uh sure it's
about politics is all about money
tony cuello knows that and here's
probably one of the biggest money
raisers in democratic party recent
democratic party history it's the public
at large as you've traveled around and
talked about your book know this i don't
think they i don't i think they're
getting wise i think they're getting
wise and they know that something has to
i think people the voting public
whatever you want to call that group out
there that elects the
members of congress and the senate year
after year after year but i think these
people uh in the in the out in the
country are realizing that something has
to be done
to control
access to money and the way money has
become so much a part of politics and it
seems as though the best they've come up
with so far whether it's constitutional
or not is term limits i think people are
upset
about the way money is spent and what
money is spent on and the way money has
become so much a part of what politics
is today
tony cuellar probably wouldn't have said
what he said to me a year ago today
there was a profile of him recently in
one of the papers i think it was new
york times or washington post i can't
recall which
very very careful about what he said but
i thought that was a pretty revealing
comment
is this a
an honest town
uh well truth in washington of course is
always fluent i mean truth truth here
tends to be
spoken
truth tends to be what works
uh i
polit politics is the art of motivating
people to do what you want them to do
whether it's vote for you support an
issue turn out at a rally appear at a
demonstration this is all part of the
washington uh
washington show business i mean
washington is a town for performing
whether it's performing in a
demonstration in front of the supreme
court rallying around some cause on the
capitol steps uh appearing at a luncheon
speech at the national press club
talking to constituents entertaining
constituents putting flags out in the
hallway
washington is a town full of actors of
one sort or another and acting is the
art of presenting illusions and that's
what politics really is or has become
you say this these are your words
financial service not eloquence
is the ultimate measure of success in
congress
what's that mean
well once again providing uh constituent
service now constituent service can take
many forms as you know
um
providing giving people back home
the money they the money they need to
build airports roads uh
factories constituent service is helping
people locate their social security
checks and constituent service is
building super highways the very funny
story about
robert byrd when he was running for
reelection in the late 80s against a
sort of an upstart west virginia lawyer
the upstart west virginia lawyer a guy
named jay wolf decided that byrd wasn't
bringing enough money back to the state
and he would he would teach him a lesson
by walking
the state which is a typical campaign
move but he'd walk the state of west
virginia from the panhandle to the ohio
river
and to demonstrate to the people that
his commitment would be to to bring
money more money to west virginia faster
than bird who'd bird had been doing it
and bird was in declining in in age and
and burgess wasn't providing west
virginia with the kind of money that
it had been used to getting from the
government
every every move this guy would walk a
mile and bird would fund another highway
every every every every day the guy was
on his track across west virginia bird
funneled more and more money into the
state finally by the time the guy the
poor fellow jay wolf gets to the ohio
river bird had had dumped about 16
million dollars into into west virginia
so bird won he lost
that's that's how
members of congress get reelected you do
you do financial favors for the folks
back home whether the favors are for
individuals and small or for
fat cats and large favors that's one of
the ways you ingratiate yourself to the
people
this book is put out by scribner's
scrivener how did it all start
well it started with a conversation uh
that i had with my agent uh henry dunow
about uh maybe two and a half years ago
we're kicking around the subject of a
book on capitol hill book on washington
uh at the time i had just come back from
moscow where i had been
working on an earlier book and had
finished just finished that uh book on
capitalism in in the new russia
and uh we were joking about russia's
attempts to become a democracy and
and
one thing led to another and the idea
for a book on capitol hill
was generated and we went to talk to an
editor at scriveners who liked the idea
and um
at the time we we were sort of kicking
around this notion that 1994 clinton had
not been
elected yet it was early in the uh
in the primary season as i recall uh or
maybe maybe in the summer towards the
end of the primary season and we we all
sort of got the idea that the 1994
congressional election would be a
referendum of some sort on on
congressional behavior congressional
ethics
uh and uh nobody had any idea at the
time certainly none of us had any idea
at the time that it would become the
sort of national referendum on
washington
uh that it that it's become
dedicated for brendan who's that that's
my son
how where is he
he lives here in washington he uh and uh
and he goes to a high school here in
houston maryland 16 years old works on
the
works in the high school newspaper
gonna do the same thing i don't know
he's a good writer
some of the things in here come pretty
close to home for this network and i
want to read one and you and i never met
each other so no never
uh the gallery also contains eight
remote controlled television cameras
bolted down at key angles that cover the
place from wall-to-wall as if it were a
convenience store in a high crime
neighborhood which in a way is what it
is what are you talking about
well in a sense capitol hill is one stop
shopping for people looking around for
favors and for of course it's the place
where congressmen are always members of
congress always shopping around for uh
financial favors from supporters
but capitol hill is a dangerous a
dangerous place uh
you you can't i i was reminded
immediately when the first time i saw
the viewer i should say television
cameras no they're not ours they're not
yours they belong to the house and they
belong to the senate
you lease them no they belong to the
house and senate you run it no how does
that work they run it all we do is plug
in like any other news organization you
plug in just plug in anybody has access
to it anybody has access to that
uh well when i saw the cameras and i was
reminded immediately of a 7-eleven and
the way when you go into the 7-eleven to
buy a burrito burger or something like
that you're being followed by this
little mini cam and the the cameras move
there are no cameramen in there they
they sort of move independent of of any
human human operator
and it immediately struck me this place
is just like a 711 and these are like
anti-theft devices
and when you think of the sort of place
capitol hill is if if uh if you live in
washington it's a fair washington is a
fairly dangerous city there are a couple
of carjacking jackings every week and
violent crime all over the place capitol
hill is is sort of america's the most
politicized free fire zone in a sense
very dangerous neighborhood and the
danger takes many forms and those
cameras just
caught my imagination
you say most senators it was clear by
now had no idea what they were voting on
which is the way congress usually works
uh i you know i think the health care uh
bill illustrated this uh pretty well
people were confessing at one point
there during the health care debate that
they had no idea was in any of these
bills they didn't hadn't read them
they hadn't uh
they hadn't had time to really form uh
intelligent opinions about anything
legislation was flying so fast and
furious as it often does
members will confess often after they
leave uh they'll they'll tell you how uh
how chaotic how impossible it is to to
read things to know exactly what you're
doing all the time uh and they make
these confessions conveniently when they
decide to retire and go into lobbying or
some other
uh allied profession back in the back
you say that in 1992 of the 121
departing members of congress
more than 40 percent followed the path
of least resistance into quote
government relations unquote otherwise
known as lobbying
um well the record speaks for itself
they're a huge number of course that was
a huge number of departing members uh
some of the uh some of the former
members who are in lobbying uh will tell
you that the field is becoming so
saturated now with former members that
it's difficult even for the most plugged
in
ex-members of the house and senate to
sell their services to uh to to bidders
after uh after they get out of office
there are just a lot of ex-members
looking to do what they do best or know
best and that's lobby their their
buddies back in back in congress uh i
remember guy vanderja said something
very funny to me he had
i think he was he'd been in office for
maybe uh 15 terms i'm not quite sure but
a long time a member of the republican
member of the house and he was defeated
in the primary and he said uh well he
said it took me a while to get used to
that it was it was depressing and and
all but he said i realized something
the guy who beat me did me a favor and
did himself a favor he tripled both of
our salaries um
there are lots of uh there are lots of
ways for congressmen who lose in
primaries or general elections to get uh
to to come down from there
from the sorrow of their defeat but a
lot of them stay in washington doing
what they've always done which is
selling influence or being available for
consultation with people with money what
impact does it have that members can
always go back on the floor of the house
anytime they want to i think that's
amazing uh well of course that's a good
way to lobby other members to do what
people who pay you to deliver their
message want you to do they aren't
allowed to lobby suppose well come on
uh they're there their in influence is
is is felt they can lobby in the cloak
room they can lobby uh in the hallways
they can go and sit and listen it's
they're members of a club it's a it's a
it's a club and you be if as long as you
play the game according to the rules of
the system you're a lifetime member but
a member recently who had served three
months in jail larry smith from florida
came back to the floor in the cloak room
and the speaker ordered him to stop
doing whatever he was doing i don't know
what he was doing but you know it didn't
look good reporters probably saw and but
it goes on all the time
you say lawmakers love when disaster
strikes
money you know money from heaven
uh earthquakes fires this gives this
gives members of congress an opportunity
to tack
uh private
bills this is this is one of the great
charades on capitol hill uh
i talk about the mississippi river flood
in
19 last year in 93
uh
it took congress over two and a half
weeks to appropriate money needed to
keep these people from going under all
up and down the mississippi valley while
members fought one another over over
private spending bills that were that
were tacked onto this thing um
there there were bills to renovate
railroad stations and bills to employ
unemployed gang members and to teach
people how to do this and that and the
other thing meanwhile these poor
families these poor farm families out in
the mississippi valley are treading
water waiting for uh congress to help
them it became a huge scandal but
disasters are an opportunity to uh it's
like a
congressional bingo in a way it's an
opportunity to tack on all kinds of
private spending things to emergency
relief legislation
uh earlier in your introduction you say
that the interests are joined at the
wallet to 535 congressional profit
centers
what do you mean by that do they make a
profit in these offices well they have
to raise money and you can look at that
you can call that whatever you want uh
congressional offices members of
congress as i said have to make
15 16 17 18 20 000 a week to pay
for their re-election campaigns most of
that money going to meet buying media
buying advertising
uh
you're not talking about every member of
congress sorry because 17 000 we're
talking we're talking we're talking
average some of these races some senate
races cost uh we'll look at the
huffington uh feinstein race in
california but you're lumping the senate
and the house together i mean lumping
the senate and the house together and
taking an average
senate senate races are more expensive
depending on the state depending on the
size of the state house races can run
anywhere from
a couple hundred thousand dollars to
over a million dollars huffington spent
uh
michael huffington spent 400 a record
4.3 i think million dollars to win his
house seat in 92 he's spending 17 18
million who knows how much on his senate
race in california this year
it's expensive
and if you want to win and win
convincingly it can be very expensive
on the back of the book you have uh some
endorsements uh one of them is from uh
bill proxmeier
by the way was that your idea or
scribner's
uh don't know
don't know why scribner's gets in touch
but publishers get in they send books
out to people when a book is written
uh
i suggested some names i can't remember
i suggested uh proxima or not as
somebody might find this interesting but
they had some names and but they
uh publishing a show business too
uh
the publisher sent a manuscript a book
around her galleries of the book around
to lots of people
he says i thought my 31 years in the
senate had taught me all i wanted to
laugh about in washington until i read
club fed how wrong i was bill thomas
makes our capital even more hysterically
funny than i had ever realized did you
mean this book to be funny
i meant it to be entertaining
i'll tell you capitol hill is a great
source of entertainment i think one of
the reasons that people probably watch
c-span i know it's one of the reasons i
watch when something interesting on the
hill is going on it's fabulous
entertainment if stone once told me he
said look
uh i was talking to him in connection
with something i was doing a few years
ago and he's we were talking about how
amusing politics can be and he said the
greatest source of amusement in politics
is the public record
look at the public record and you will
become addicted to the to the things
that are the humor it contains and uh
this
i found that to be true um but i wanted
the book to be entertaining and i wanted
people to learn something from it and be
informed but i wanted them to uh you
know in
in in literature
you want people to keep turning the
pages and the way to do that is to keep
their interest and keep them keep them
entertained and informed probably at the
same time that's what i tried for what
do you find people's to be people's
favorite chapter
uh i've gotten a lot of a lot of uh
comments on um there's a chapter in
there called caesar's palace on the
potomac uh
i've i don't know how long i've heard
the term hollywood on the potomac
applied to washington but it really it's
more like las vegas um considering the
money that has to be brought in and the
kind of uh
this sort of
like i like to call call it lounge act
type style entertainment that goes on
but
but it's more like las vegas it's more
like a casino than a movie studio
although obviously there are a lot of
movie studio aspects to it as well but
there's a prayer
that begins that chapter the senate
chaplain says a prayer i'm going to read
it
as you wish sovereign lord of history
and the nations
we pray for the senators running for
reelection
he's retiring by the way mr reverend
give wisdom to those who direct their
campaigns give the senators special
persuasion in speech and provide
wherever needed adequate campaign funds
we pray in his name through whom thou
dost promise to supply all our needs
according to your riches in glory amen
can i get you
uh
this was
that's a prayer
it's a prayer on the senate floor found
in the congressional record i mean i
wasn't there at the time but it was in
the congressional record i'm assuming it
was set on the president on the senate
floor to open up
a session of that august body was it
said with a straight face
uh it was a prayer
i'm assuming eyes were you know bent
towards heaven at least on some people's
parts you know if you uh if you watch
members of the house and senate when
these prayers are usually said they're
talking to one another and doing all
sorts of things but at this particular
time i'm sure they were paying attention
these are the kinds of prayers that
members of congress fully expect to be
answered of course for the more
successful ones they are give wisdom to
those who direct their campaigns
give the senator special persuasion and
speech and provide wherever needed
adequate campaign funds
uh
by the way is one side better than the
other one side meaning
democrats conservative republican
democrat in what sense in any sense
better at more honest
uh it's politics it's all politic
there's a you know
there is a difference between the two
parties it goes it goes beyond name tags
uh but when it comes right down to it
they all
they're there to preserve a system which
keeps them in office and they'll join
together in prayer
uh in this case or in in in allying
themselves with one another to preserve
to preserve their jobs and
when it comes to changing the system
you'll find members of opposing parties
agreeing
uh more than disagreeing when the
alternative is is changing the system
and it's in in ways that might eliminate
their their employment
uh you have the this from
expense reports for campaign 98
filed with the federal election
commission during 1993 how did you find
those
uh
fec
federal elections
senator dale bumpers and arkansas
democrats spent over twenty seven
hundred dollars from his campaign fund
to rent an apartment in little rock that
serves as bumper's primary arkansas
residents is that legal
uh to campaign if it's a campaign
expense
and if you can make an argument for the
fact that this is a campaign expense
sure
senator frank murkowski a republican
from alaska was reimbursed by his
campaign fund for more than fifteen
thousand in unspecified plane fare and
other travel expenses including 305
dollars for an overnight stay in tokyo
what's wrong with that
nothing
why'd you list it there
uh it i think people should know well if
it's a campaign expense it's a campaign
expense uh but i think people should
know that campaigns can
go anywhere congressional committees can
go to barbados to discuss
the implications of a tax bill with
insurance lobbyists
politicians travel far and wide in the
effort to be re-elected senator john bro
a louisiana democrat who had 1.5 million
left in his campaign treasury after the
92 elections by the way can they keep
this forever it can carry over
paid himself 106 925 for travel
restaurant and entertainment expenses
all related to his re-election bid in
1998.
you have to start early
bro also reimbursed himself 1500 that he
paid to attend mardi gras events and one
thousand fifty dollars for tickets to
the new orleans saints games
public appearance related to generating
interest for his re-election
do people that give campaign
contributions know that these people
spend the money in the way you listed it
here some do some don't some uh some
don't care i think the the little man
may not may not know but i think some
people do and some people don't care
some lobbyists on get parts 167
63 person quote steering committee
unquote were reportedly asked to fork
over twenty five hundred dollars each a
cover charge that represented a
potential payday for the honoree of more
than four hundred thousand dollars what
do you why did you list that
uh once again i think this is
interesting information
people who who vote for politicians and
and uh and maybe don't follow politics
as much as viewers of c-span do
don't don't know how important
fundraisers and social activities that
are aimed at raising money for
re-election campaigns are in this town
every night and you could eat free if
you put your mind to it in washington
going from one fundraiser to another
monday through thursday in in
most of the time without having to leave
capitol hill
often
you know people assume that lobbyists
are out there chasing members of
congress
tracking them down grabbing them kicking
and screaming into their in into their
offices to talk to them about this piece
of legislation or that it's the other
way around
it's the members of congress who are
chasing after lobbyists
when daniel moynihan became after benson
left the senate to become treasury
secretary and moynihan became chairman
of the senate finance committee his
office sent around an invitation to
lobbyists to come and meet him
and donate some money to his uh his
campaign coffers
and the invitation stressed how
important he would be now in his new
position as chairman of the finance
committee and that
55 percent or 60 of all tax and spending
measures would would filter through his
committee so you better get to know him
when this invitation uh got into the uh
got into the media uh the event was
cancelled and you know moynihan's face
must have turned ten shades of scarlet
and uh
this is this is part of the ugly
business the ugly behind the scenes
business of raising money that
politicians don't like people to know
about and when they when
people find out about it when the press
finds out about it
lots of embarrassment can occur you have
a chapter called welcome to the club um
and it won't be long that there will be
a new
a new club new members club new members
uh the average pay was 70
now 70 per member
but in the case of the three house
democrats the boost was bigger than that
in other words you're getting a salary
increase salary what that's
what that congressional house salary
meant in terms of a boost in personal
income for these new members uh for
read that again i think it was 70
percent the average was 70 percent
but the case of three house democrats
the boost was bigger than that and you
list eva clayton who was making 8 000
before she came to congress elizabeth
first of oregon who was making 5 000
selling grapes and in california dan
dan hamburg was making 2262 on
unemployment and unemployment
compensation now let me go back and read
that 70 percent
of each new member each new member back
in 92 where there were 110 new members
right this is congress now not this
congress increased their salary by 70
percent yeah
is it always been that way
uh i i couldn't tell you it was just
what made this group interesting was
that first of all there were so many of
them secondly they came promising to
reform the system and stop talking to
influence peddlers and not take so much
pack money
they ended up the first six months this
new group of reform congressmen uh and
women uh was was in office
they ended up collecting 50 percent more
money from pacs in the preceding
freshman class what's up wait let me say
what about pat because you write a lot
about packs how does it work
it's pretty comp look the rules are
always changing to tell you the truth i
don't know what's going on right now
with with pax but uh
there is a there is a there is a limit
of
on the amount of money that members of
congress can accept from pacs it's five
thousand dollars i believe are they bad
well you know they're they're packs
covering everything there are there are
sexual uh
orientation packs there are snack food
packs there are religious packs there
are golfing packs there are grassroots
packs there are big industry packs
members would tell you again if they
were sitting here that a pack is the
most democratic way of getting a group
to have any power at all by all putting
bits and pieces of their money in a pot
in a pot and and you participate in the
sharing of this money
it rem it i don't i it looks bad to take
lots of pac money i think congressmen
realize this looks bad to people many
see no alternative to pay other than
taking pac money to pay the expenses for
the incredible campaign bills that they
incur when they run for re-election
pac the the act the acronym has become a
bad word in politics
another way to get together the money
you need to run for re-election of
course is have to go have the government
pay and there was an effort to
minimize the influence of pacs last year
by increasing the amount of money
congressmen and senators get from the
federal government to run for reelection
it's an area that needs to be looked at
and it's an area that needs to be
cleaned up but congress of course the
only institution that can clean up
congress is congress itself and congress
has shown over the years a tremendous
reluctance to get down and do the do the
hard work of of cleaning up what pacs do
and the kind of money packs can give and
other organizations can give to members
running for re-election you say uh in
the chapter on caesar's palace that
money in washington is a byproduct of
relationships can you explain more about
that
um
well
politics in washington is a large part
of politics in washington politicking in
washington
is is playing a game it's going to lunch
it's going it's having fundraisers it's
getting to know people it's getting to
know people who can introduce you to
other people it's going to the right
cocktail parties where the right people
are in attendance and the right people
always means people with connections to
to money
washington is a town where you you buy
access either by being influential
yourself or by paying for it
there are two things that get the
attention of members of congress money
and fear
uh and you're seeing in a way right now
with this election both of those things
in operation
uh
congress members of congress probably
have never been so afraid of losing
their jobs as they are right now and
they've never needed more money
to run more ads on television to
influence more voters that they should
keep their jobs but all of this
washington is a is an immense buddy
system
you become friends with people on the
hill once you've been in office for a
while you remain friends with those
people after you leave office so you can
deal with them and work with them and
influence them as a lobbyist in your in
your golden years when you're no longer
serving
but need to have these [ __ ] need to keep
going back to the cloakroom need to keep
going to the hospital or need to keep
meeting these people at fundraisers and
receptions
anybody uh
give you a strong negative reaction to
your book
not so far
ever talked to a member about your book
not yet
not yet when you travel and you talk
about the book do you find that people
out in the country
know all these stories i mean if you
live here a lot of these stories in your
book are stuff that we've some of some
have been i heard about
out in the out in the country people are
amazed by by what goes on in washington
and and
in in some cases less informed about
what happens here i think people in
washington who live here and work here
tend to accept a lot of this as business
as usual oh so and so did that oh
so-and-so had to resign or so-and-so was
forced to give this back
next day is another day here uh people
uh who don't live in washington or
people beyond the beltway tend to take
this after it sinks in a little more
serious and get very very upset
angry you get angry phone calls i've
been on some talk shows recently in
other parts of the country
and the anger um
that that callers and and viewers
express is just amazing it stunned me
that people are as upset and agitated
about not only their members who have
always in the past had
people have hated congress in general at
least paul suggested but but
but have sort of liked their own members
or appreciated the work their own
members have done for them but the anger
that this is not scientific by any means
the anger that
uh you hear from from people about
congress in general and their own
senators and congressmen it's it stunned
me
are you angry
not particularly no
and then i'm i suppose it's a little
outrageous and the behavior is scanning
but i've lived here too long i guess in
a way to be completely outraged by it
but uh i'm stunned by by what what
amazes me is the and this will always
amaze me i think is the ability of of
members of congress or house of
representatives in the senate once
they've uh had a scandal a break in in
their
you know in their lives their ability
just to go out and face the public as if
nothing has happened the the
ability to act their way through uh
through scandals and through exposes of
one sort or another it fascinates me
there's almost a sort of penitential
sheik uh that
that is in operation on capitol hill the
worse the scandal the greater the
opportunity to appear human
and it's that it's that appearing human
and that ability to act your way through
a a scandal a money scandal a behavioral
scandal that to me is just absolutely
amazing maybe maybe the voting public is
so accustomed to afternoon television
and to donahue and sally jesse and maury
and oprah that all of this now is just
seen as part of this american
dysfunctionalism that we have to accept
and embrace but members of congress have
really learned how to uh how to do this
very well i think that's what i don't
know if you call it outrage but that's
what really amazes me this ability to to
have something awful happen in your
career or personal life and then the
next day uh pretend as if nothing has
happened and go on with your business
uh straightforward again we
never met you and i don't i have any
idea what you're about to say this but
i'd be interested in your perception of
what televising the congress impact has
had on the public sure
positive negative
oh very positive i think the more uh
there should be more of it obviously i
don't know what else you could show in
c-span because you seem to show
everything i remember once i was
getting back to this
freshman orientation thing you had a
camera
on a bus that was taking republican new
incoming republican members
to a meeting in annapolis uh for a
republican orientation program i
couldn't believe it i thought where else
does c sp
the next the next place will be the
men's room i guess but c span so show
shows so much it's hard to imagine what
else you could serve but sure no i mean
the more people see the more educated
they are as as to what's going on i
think c-span's played a big uh
unsolicited testimonial here it's played
a big part
in exposing the reality of politics and
the reality of capitol hill rituals and
the reality of what goes on here to more
people than ever before and people the
more people see the more they don't like
but let me take the other turn on
because this really my question wasn't
about
uh the positive or negative of whether
we're even there is that the members
over there
some would say that by showing this
process up close is not a positive and
you can't ever get a perfect situation
and the public again gets a distorted
view because
again when the chamber is empty and
they're during special orders they're
off doing other things like going to
committee meetings and they can't be
place at
one time right i guess that's the what
do the members think well i think a lot
of them a lot of them see it again as an
opportunity to perform you're talking
about special orders i remember dornan's
performance is kind of one man late show
during the 92 presidential uh campaign
when he just sort of held court every
night doing doing a number on bill
clinton for weeks and weeks and weeks
a lot of members see this as an
opportunity to perform to generate sound
bites look
the important thing they have to do is
get on the air um
and one way for members of congress to
do that is to is to create some drama to
create a crisis or an emergency
situation bring it up on the floor of
the house or the senate hope that the
networks pick it up uh carol mosley
braun did this with the uh remember the
renewal of the of the trademark for the
daughters of the confederacy
uh she she took that issue ran with it
made a made an emergency uh crisis out
of it
got on television this is this is what
television has done for for the house
and senate but it's given it's given
congressman one more way to perform
couldn't that be a negative
well i mean when people perform they
reveal a lot about themselves and the
more the more someone's on stage the
more you see about them and a lot of
these people of course don't know when
to leave the stage which is a big part
of show business you have to know when
to shut up
and um
and those who don't know that tend to
put their their feet in their mouth as
dornan did when he when he did his late
show you have a chapter and we'll switch
subjects entirely all about the library
of congress and the driving force
variant of congress
james
has um has always interested me i i'm
interested in russia and uh russian
culture
russian politics
uh billington is a russian scholar and
that's what started it i
did a a profile of billington for the la
times magazine uh
a couple of years ago and was at a party
that he gave at at the library of
congress
ostensibly to
an open a harriman collection there were
some letters and documents that april
harriman had donated the library of
congress and this collection was being
made available to scholars and billing
so billington saw this as an opportunity
to have a cocktail party and he invited
people
i i couldn't believe i was seeing some
of these people george cannon uh richard
helms uh
uh mcnamara pamela herrera was like and
it was a couple of months after the
after uh the
coup had failed and the soviet union was
on the way out at this point and it was
almost like a victory party i got to ask
who was george who's george cannon
george cannon is the father of the
containment theory uh george cannon was
a former uh
there still is a
sovietologist a russian scholar mcnamara
was a former
robert mcnamara former secretary of
defense richard richard helms former
head of the cia it was almost like a
victory party a victory over communism
party but you could see billington
working the crowd the library of
congress has to and there were some
members of congress there from the
committee that oversees uh the funding
for the library
uh and these are people that billington
has to curry favor with but but
billington was working the crowd in a
way that i'd never really seen anybody
do that before in the washington
cocktail circuit i used to be the editor
of dossier magazine which no longer
exists and it the purpose of dossier was
to sort of cover the washington social
scene so i've seen a lot of cocktail
circuitry and i'd never seen anyone so
good at it as billington this one
particular night from his rumpled tuxedo
that said i need money to just his
ingratiating manner it was it was
amazing to watch
and then i i started to look more and
more into what billington had done
and billington must have been the envy
of every member of congress now here
billington is not subject to the same
kind of money raising restrictions that
members of congress are and billington
has created the madison council to raise
money for the library this is all for
extracurricular kind of library things
like exhibits and
events
and members of the madison council could
pay anywhere from ten thousand to a
hundred thousand dollars a year
for the opportunity to hold uh parties
themselves there at the library which is
one of the great party venues in
washington if if sort of atmospherics is
is everything in washington and
atmospherics or would help you create
interest in giving you money so you can
do great works the library of congress
is a great place for parties anything
wrong with anything he's done so far no
no not at all not at all uh
you did you do say that he was trying to
change a procedure so that people would
pay a user fee for some of the things
billington wanted to uh this is this is
i don't know if this is right or wrong i
mean uh
that requires maybe a philosopher to
decide that but billington wanted to
charge here the library of congress
needs money to do the things it does it
provides the library of congress
provides a lot of free services to
companies that that take this
information and turn around and sell it
for they have to pay for it
they don't have to pay for it no
copyright free uh well it depends on
what the information is but the library
of congress just generates lots and lots
of information that uh data banks and
resource and research services then turn
around and sell to their customers and
billington wants a piece of the action i
can't blame him you say that they have
400 million a year budget they get from
the government approximately 400 million
they have 400
532 miles of shelves 100 million items
and that um they have the personal
papers about 23 presidents and a
thousand members of congress and of
course billington is very good at at
getting new material all that of course
new materials flooding into the library
of congress one of the big problems
there is cataloging all this stuff it's
called a rear edge all of the
information all of the books pamphlets
whatever that have not yet been
cataloged and available for for
you know research
billington as a matter of fact was in
moscow during the coup in august of 1991
and he had there's a
library of congress uh office is a
congressional research office in moscow
i don't know if it's still in operation
but it was
and billington was had set this up to to
sort of help the douma the russian
congress
organize itself and create some research
material for itself and during the coup
billington while billington is sort of
watching all of this stuff and
participating on the fringes of all of
this
he had people from the library of
congress out picking up leaflets and
flyers and manifestos and pamphlets
really kind of a a historian's dream
come true and he was out there with his
forces street sweeping for material
interesting guy but what happened to his
proposal that people
in business would have to pay shut down
of course why well um
people in business who sell information
are generally big campaign contributors
uh the big campaign contributors don't
want to have competition from the
library of congress uh the big campaign
contributors who give money to important
members of committees that might oversee
the activity of the library of congress
said this is a this is not a good thing
and billington came before the committee
that oversees the library asked for
permission to sell some of this
information and got a resounding no
because there's a new congress soon to
come in let me go back to something you
quoted from members
that came in in 1992 here's
maria cantwell a democrat
from tom foley's home state of
washington will be a force to be
reckoned with watch out
uh
what happened they weren't quite the
force to be reckoned with that they
promised to be uh once again very
shortly it's very difficult to be a
force to be reckoned with when you're
operating outside the system on in
congress uh this was something she said
of course before she got here
uh and once she got here once other
members got here they saw how hard it
would be to work outside the system to
change the system as outsiders
is literally there are no outsiders i
mean if you don't have a power base if
you don't play
your if you don't play party politics
you're not going to be helped with your
campaign your re-election campaign
if you don't go along you don't if you
don't get along you don't go along and
you don't go along you don't get along
and if you don't do the things that are
necessary to keep the system working
properly you're not going to find
yourself able to do much of anything do
you really mean the following statement
the main concern of every washington
politician is job security
yeah yes i do yeah sure
you mean they're not here for their
constituents
there's a very thin line between public
service and and self-service uh
constituents are a means to an end for
most politicians cons most politicians
have very very little respect for the
quote people who send them who send them
here they like to talk to them they like
to speak to them they like to shake
their hands they like lots of them
around when they appear in public
but what
i i think if you if once again i i look
at what fred grandy said the other day
fred grandy uh the congressman from love
boat
who uh
who tried to become the governor of iowa
didn't work and he's now leaving the
hill
like most people who leave a congress he
had a lot to say about how congress
doesn't work what's uh what's funny now
is how congressmen especially
ex-congressmen former congressmen and
senators are trying to blame
constituents constituents need to know
more about the about how bills become
law constituents need to know more about
what goes on here become more
sophisticated before they judge us
um
i just i don't think that that
congressmen care much about voters until
it comes time to count votes election at
election time
what do you what do you say to people
watching that
are angry and expect a vote this time
around will create change in january
what are the chances
well they'd better wake up and sort of
realize
what does create change if fear is one
of the things that motivates members of
congress to act or to change themselves
to change their act
maybe a a constant message from voters
will work after a while but as this last
class of so-called reformers has shown
electing reformers doesn't always create
the kind of reform on capitol hill that
that
outsiders now become insiders promise to
bring to the job when they come here it
it just doesn't work the way it's
supposed to at least the way people
running for office say it well
you say while not exactly giving the
house and senate a triple a rating for
trust and integrity ornstein and man
make it sound as though it's misguided
outsiders
uh it is misguided
outsiders who are doing all the harm
tom mann and norman ornstein who we
norman ornstein's been here on book
notes but we've seen both gentlemen
uh many many times in the national media
being quoted what was your point there
uh those two uh did a ornstein works at
the american enterprise institute of
think tank in washington and thomas mann
not the not the novelist works at the uh
brookings institute and the two of them
got together
and uh wrote a i guess it's a pamphlet
or a booklet on reforming congress and
they there's an introduction to that and
they talk about congress bashing and
that uh that the country has become
obsessed with congress with bashing
congress the way to reform congress is
not to bash it but to do the hard work
necessary to change the institution one
of the points they they sort of they
overlook and don't really make and this
is a problem i think with the washington
media
you can look at something so long from
the inside you don't really see it
anymore the congress bashers are are not
not the that great mass of american
voters out there it's members of
congress themselves this is how you get
reelected you bash congress congress is
full of the the biggest congress bashers
imaginable this is the one of the ways
one of the tried and true ways you run
for reelection i think what's so funny
now about this current election is how
desperately all all of the people up for
up for reelection the 33 senators or 35
senators how many however many it is and
the and the entire house how they're
trying to distance themselves from what
they've been doing uh the act of running
for re-election now for running running
for your old job or to get your old job
back is the act of sorting of pretending
that you never had the job in the first
place so it's not the people who are
bashing congress if they are they're
taking a cue from from members of
congress to a pretty good job on their
own
this is the book called club fed power
money sex and violence on capitol hill
our author guest has been bill thomas we
thank you thank you very much
[Music]
you